[Music]
the federal bureau of land management
says it is moving forward with plans to
gather a record number of wild horses
from public ranges nevada and other
western states blm wants to gather 23
thousand mustangs despite recent deaths
and illnesses among captive horses at
crowded facilities in colorado and
wyoming tonight blm officials holding a
briefing for the public the event was
supposed to explain why
145 mustangs died in colorado and why
more than 1200 horses are currently
infected with another illness nicknamed
strangles at a facility in the state of
wyoming hundreds of questions submitted
from the public for tonight's event but
only one question was asked about how
blm plans to prevent future outbreaks of
death and disease at the government
corrals
the comprehensive animal welfare program
and their review
they found that you know there were some
stopping shortages some maintenance
issues like i mentioned earlier
we're addressing the stopping shortages
of actively right now as well as those
maintenance issues and i think that
being able to
take care of horses more quickly at a
facility will will help alleviate some
of that pressure other than that
statement that they are addressing the
problems no other details were provided
about how blm plans to prevent more
deaths and disease among the 58 000
captured mustangs that it oversees one
critic of the wild horse program scott
beckstead of animal wellness action
reacting to tonight's event saying quote
this was an opportunity for the blm to
be honest with the american people and
the agency blew it big time